i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight now this
week we've documented how democrats are
scrambling to find a plan b
should biden choose not to run again in
2024 we know he's not going to run well
tonight we are very comfortable saying
that one man has risen to the top of the
heap
[Applause]
now he might not be able to raise the
roof like a normal person but pete
butterjudge has rocketed to the top of
the democrats secret 2024 wish list we
will explain why ahead
but first
the mouse and the apple versus america
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now it turns out that mickey has more
friends than just minnie and pluto
another goofy character is entering
their new political alliance with the
hard left
his name is tim cook
the ceo of apple and his corporate spin
meisters employ the same tactics as
disney's by mischaracterizing the laws
that they spend millions of dollars
lobbying against as
anti-lgbtq when in reality these laws
are aimed at protecting kids and women
now according to politico behind the
scenes apple is one of the most active
corporate advocates for lgbtq rights
according to four organizers on the
ground in states where legislation is
moving the company has tried to leverage
its greatest assets the popularity of
its products and the size of its
employee base in the u.s to crush the
legislation
first
laws such as florida's parental rights
and education bill
they're not anti-lgbtq
they are pro-child and they're aimed at
protecting little ones from pre-k
through third grade
now we don't call laws banning kids from
driving cars anti-automobile do we right
and laws that prevent biological males
from competing against women they're not
anti-anything either
they protect girls and women who've
often worked their entire lives to excel
at the highest levels of athletics so
these common sense measures again being
passed in states around the country are
supported by an overwhelming percentage
of americans especially when those
americans are told for instance that
nothing in the florida bill prohibits
the word gay from being said in school
activists though burrowed inside these
companies they know all this they're not
stupid which is why they have to lie
about the laws
now their position
that it is somehow okay for schools to
tutor children in the complexities of
sexual and gender identity
it's indefensible
and will not stop calling them out on it
ever
or stop exposing these corporations for
funding efforts to rob our children of
their innocence and then to subvert the
core rights of parents to raise their
children with their own cultural and
religious values
now the angle and our friend tucker
carlson have caused quite a stir this
week in wokeland
we aired internal disney videos courtesy
of chris ruffo
that just blew the lid off of how
radical the company that gave us
pinocchio and snow white had become
now they're obviously worried
and they've dispatched their media
allies to try to protect them like
michelle goldberg she's a liberal flunky
for the new york times and she obviously
saw how effective our coverage was
and it apparently gave her a case of the
vapors
she especially took issue with the use
of the word grooming that we used in
regards to adults in the classroom who
are insistent about discussing intimate
sexual topics with five-year-olds
now to justify the law the right has
taken to accusing anyone who opposed it
posing it as wanting to expose young
kids to explicit material in order to
prime them for abuse the q on idea that
the right's political opposition is a
cabal of pedophiles has gone mainstream
okay first we didn't say any of that
michelle
um the new york times though just like
corporate behemoths like apple they're
complete frauds when it comes to the
issues they supposedly care so much
about anyway
so if you asked the executive editor of
the times
which is the bigger threat to america
today is it trump supporters or china
how do you think that answer
and as for apple well they're tied up
financially big time with the ccp which
has zero respect for minority rights of
any kind and i'm talking gay rights
muslim rights christian rights or any
ethnic rights
just a few months ago the information
published a stunning report revealing
that tim cook himself made a secret deal
with chinese authorities back in 2016
that was worth more than
ready to get ready for it 275 billion
dollars
now this five-year agreement was made
over the course of several in-person
meetings that cook had in china
he was trying to salvage apple's
relationship with chinese officials they
thought the company wasn't contributing
enough to china's economy
well they got they got what they wanted
and as was reported this week apple is
exploring new suppliers for memory chips
used in its iphones including a
potentially first chinese supplier
so here's my question for tim
where's your advocacy against china's
prison camps for muslims
or was your advocacy against the ccp
bulldozing churches and terrorizing
religious orders
in fact cook has nothing but praise for
china
now china plays a
leadership position for the world in
in
many different areas china has
extraordinary skills for us
the
the uh
number one attraction is the quality of
people
and uh
and uh we so we've had an extraordinary
relationship over uh three decades
really
the extraordinary people who subjugate
other people
now silence about their chinese
overlords but vocal opposition to laws
ensuring basic decency in the united
states think about that for a moment
now this activism got really ramped up
as you'll recall call during the george
floyd chaos when corporations just
reflexively align themselves with all
those marxists over at blm
meanwhile remember small businesses were
being torched all across america
i like you like lori i'm outraged
sad
frustrated and angry
companies like ours must speak up
as allies to the black lives matter
movement we ended up marching uh to
support black lives matter and you've
got to start trying to do more on the
inclusion and to
end up bringing about social
social change this is not a new topic
for for ben and jerry's uh we were on
record back in 2016 in supporting a
black lives matter this is something
that comes from the values of our
business and the values of our team
ah yes the much wanted values that blm
holds such as
rioting is justified
looting can be reparations
capitalism that's evil and the nuclear
family should be abolished
and as for the value of let's say voter
integrity in georgia you know to ensure
that the ballots are actually cast by
eligible voters
this legislation is unacceptable
it is a step backwards are trying to
restrict voters access to the to the
polls
and it is disproportionately hurting
black and brown communities business
leaders cannot remain silent on
important issues whether it's racial
equity gender equity this is something
that's that's more than money uh this is
about protecting the voices of our
people
oh it was about none of that some
corporate flack just wrote all that copy
for them
that was about cow towing to one set of
political activists at the expense of
common sense and fair play
these businesses should really learn
this lesson now before it's too late
stay in your lane
because if your ceos want to dive into
contentious political issues about which
they know nothing apparently
expect to be treated like any lame
political pundit on let's say msnbc
except in your cases
you guys have products and services that
20 what for 74 million trump voters they
don't need to purchase if they don't
want to
and when republicans they get back into
power
apple and disney need to understand one
thing
everything will be on the table your
copyright and trademark protection your
special status within certain states and
even your corporate structure itself
the any trust division at justice needs
to begin the process of considering
which american companies need to be
broken up once and for all for
competition's sake and ultimately for
the good of the consumers who pay the
bills
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else